[Music]
Welcome everyone. Thank you so much for
coming. My name is Forest. This is Matt.
Uh and we're going to be talking to you
today about augment agent and
specifically legacy code. how we get the
most out of gnarly legacy code bases
using an AI agent. So I do not work for
Augment Code. Um I am a friend and
partner of Augment Code. So I helped to
put this talk together. Matt is from
Augment Code. So he's going to be your
best person to come to with your most
detailed technical questions after the
session. Matt, anything you want to uh
say about yourself? Yeah, uh I was once
a software engineer and then got into
the developer tool space. Um, I was at
Postman for a number of years and then
got really excited by the the AI boom.
So, I've been at Augment for the last
two years or so. Um, I'm a solutions
architect. Fantastic. All right. So,
just a quick road map of where we're
going. We're going to talk a little bit
about augment agent. Uh, oh, do we not
have um
I see someone point. We good now? Okay.
Fantastic. So, we've got augment agent.
We're going to talk a little bit about
the Apollo 11 guidance computer and then
we're going to show you some really
interesting things you can do with that
codebase uh and augment agent. So,
Augment is the uh it's the product we're
going to be using today. Um you do not
need your laptop out to follow along
with this session. We will do it all in
front of your eyes, but if you want you
can sign up. There's a free trial at
augmentode.com
and uh Matt will tell you a little bit
about the most important features of
Augment Code. Yeah. Uh number one is our
context engine. So we really identified
early on that in order to get high
quality outputs from any of the models,
they require high quality input. Uh
doing that for for code bases is not
necessarily straightforward. It's not
just like text. Um so uh this is
something that we've seen in the in the
market. Uh a lot of folks think that
there's a way to do this. We spent two
years building a proprietary system that
can lift the right knowledge from
codebase and pass it over to the models.
And we think that results in higher
quality outputs and more accurate
understanding. Uh we're a plugin to
existing idees. We see in a lot of
enterprise that if you've got a
10-year-old Java codebase, you're using
IntelliJ, you don't want to have to
switch. Um and then from day zero,
because we were targeting enterprise,
we've focused a lot of security
capabilities. So we have things that are
unique to us versus any other vendor
like customer manage encryption keys. We
have ISO 420001 which is a new AI ISO
standard. Uh so we really wanted to to
laser in on providing security over what
is very important uh a very important
asset in your codebase. Awesome. And
then we've got a couple of tools we'll
be referring to today. Mainly the chat
and agent modes of augment code. And
when would you use each of those Matt?
Yeah, chat is great for kind of simple
back and forth question and answer. Uh
or when you want to leverage a little
bit more control over the the models and
you just want to go one turn at a time.
Uh obviously we see that agents can
integrate into other tools are much more
capable of larger more complex tasks. Um
and then remote agents are great when
you actually want to close the lid on
your machine and allow them to continue
to run in the background and in
parallel. Yes, we did a workshop on
Tuesday that involved a contest
component and I had someone come up to
me afterwards afterwards saying, "I
don't understand how the winners were so
fast at submitting their solutions
because we had eight or nine problems we
were doing and it's possible some of
them were using remote agent to do some
of those tasks in parallel." So, it can
come in handy for that as well. All
right, so we're going to be talking
today about the Apollo 11 uh mission in
1969. I think most of us are familiar
with this, the first time humans landed
on the moon. There were three astronauts
in that capsule. Neil Armstrong, Buzz
Aldrin, and Michael Collins. But
sometimes people say there was a fourth
astronaut on the Apollo 11 mission. Does
anyone know what that astronaut was?
Yeah, the the Apollo guidance computer
or the AGC.
And the main things to know about the
AGC? So, this is used to land the lunar
module. If you've ever seen that picture
of Margaret Hamilton with like that
giant stack of papers uh with the code
on it, that was the source code for the
Apollo guidance computer. It was one
giant monolithic source file developed
over a period of several years at MIT.
in the 1960s. It was written in assembly
language. Who here has written assembly
at some point in their lives? Who put
your hand down if it was in college? All
right. So, keep your hand up if it was
in production in some cap. Yeah,
exactly. That's what I thought. Uh, so
not a lot of us are going to be able to
look at assembly code and be able to
tell you confidently what it does on
first glance. I certainly can. I haven't
written much assembly since I was in
computer systems 2011. Uh, so in some
ways, this is the ultimate legacy
codebase. It is on GitHub. You can check
it out yourself if you want. It's easy
to find. We are going to try to navigate
it well enough to see if we can
understand it and land the Lunar module
ourselves. And augment agent is going to
help us do that. So the first thing you
want to do anytime you pop open a large
legacy codebase is you want to see if
you can get your head around it, right?
Someone put a lot of their time and
mental energy into putting this codebase
together and you've got to catch up with
them. That historically has been a long
process. It's been a fraught process.
It's been an imprecise process. And AI
agents such as augment code can help a
lot with that. So, let's look at a
specific example. And I'm choosing the
1201 and 122 program alarms. If you're
an Apollo 11 history buff, you know
about these because during the final
descent onto the surface of the moon,
the astronauts called to Houston and
said, "Hey, we're getting this alarm.
It's a 122 uh the uh give us a reading
on the 122 program." This alarm went off
five times uh as the lunar module, the
Eagle, was making its descent onto the
lunar surface. And there was a question
for a moment about whether the landing
would need to be aborted. And finally,
Houston said, "No, you're okay. You can
continue." So, our question is, could we
determine that for ourselves, right? If
you were given the Apollo guidance
computer source code, would you be as
confident as Houston was to say, "No,
this is not a problem that's going to
affect the success or stability of the
mission." So, the way I would do this is
I'm going to pop open I've got VS Code
up here, and I've got uh a slightly
modified version of the Apollo 11
codebase just to orient you. It looks
like this. All right, this is uh this is
their version of assembly code. It's
truly just a bunch of two-word commands
saying move this piece of data into this
register somewhere. So, it's it's not
fantastically readable. And even if you
did a like a GP and looked for 1201 or
1202, it's not going to tell you what
the value of those alarms actually is.
So, I can go to augment chat and I can
say um what does the 1202 program alarm
do?
And let's see what it tells me.
It's generating our response. All right.
And so it's going to take a minute to
churn on that and it's going to come
back to me with a number of pieces of
information both from the codebase
itself and it will also be able to call
out to the web and it'll be able to look
there. One of the things I think is
interesting about using a chat mode like
this is it's kind of similar to calling
back to mission control in Houston. Um
and if you were to plug in like you know
some MCP servers to this right there's
it gives you an even an even larger
mission control element to work with.
Okay. So uh it's it's actually reading
this file for us. Uh uh so the ACG
executive system runs out of available
core sets. All right. And it shows us
where that happens. Look there's uh
octal value 122 right there. It explains
the number of registers there are. Uh it
explains the um yeah along with 121
novac area. So it pulled both of these
and look it went out to the web and it's
giving us the context of what actually
caused the error. It was an external
radar system being left on. And the
Apollo 11 computer was smart enough then
to offload some low priority tasks so
that it could continue executing mission
mission critical components inside the
computer. That's why they were able to
land. Uh so yeah, and then there's your
little TLDDR 122 means the computer's
trying to do too many things at once and
has run out of memory to track all the
concurrent jobs. How long would it have
taken you to figure that out on your own
reading through that codebase? Right. I
can tell you it would have taken me more
than the 30 seconds we've been talking
here. So that's pretty cool to see.
All right, the second thing I want to do
is do a little bit of code modernization
here. Now, when the Lunar module
actually landed on the surface, uh Neil
Armstrong used a routine in the Lunar
landing guidance equations file called
P65, and that was kind of like a manual
override mode. They didn't really trust
the computer enough to let it land the
eagle all by itself. Neil Armstrong kind
of had a thumb on the controls
throughout that process. There is also a
routine in that file as I discovered
called P66.
Sorry, he used P66. We're going to use
P65. P65 is full automatic. That's where
you just let the lunar module land by
itself. It turns out that augment agent
has a thing called auto mode. Yes. Yes.
Uh I'm going to show you what that looks
like. Uh so you see down in my chat
here, um I actually was on augment uh on
agent mode before. So we could have been
in chat mode, but I can also be in agent
mode. And this is going to, if I ask it
to write some code for me or to run some
code, it's not going to ask me for
permission. It's not going to wait and
have me click on something. It's just
going to go do it. I could go get a, you
know, a cup of coffee and I could let
Augment agent land on the moon for me.
So, what I'm going to do, I've added a
couple of files to this codebase. Uh,
one is called simulator.py. I wrote a
little simulator that expects a file to
exist called descent, and it expects a
class to exist in that file called lunar
descent guidance that implements the p65
algorithm. That file is not written. I'm
going to see if Augment agent can write
that file, run the simulator, and land
on the moon without any human assistance
whatsoever, just like the actual P65
would have run. Should we give it a try?
All right. So, this is my favorite
prompt to do this. It's just run
simulator.py
until it succeeds.
Do not change simulator.py. All right.
See, that's that's where it would try to
get me, right? Okay. Let's see what
happens. All right. So, what's augment
agent doing here?
All right. It's going to run the
simulator.py file and work through any
issues. So, uh Matt, any comments you
want to make about like how augment
builds its plan for what it wants to run
here? Yeah. So, it's going to use
codebase knowledge as a starting point
to figure out, you know, how it should
what tools it should run, what commands
might be important. Um, and so from
there, it can start to understand what
might be missing. Um, and then typically
you'll see the agent start to put
together the framework of a plan as to
how to solve this. So it might go and
read individual files and just start to
gather a better sense of what it's going
to take to complete the the task. So
here it's realizing at this point that
the files missing and then it's going to
start exploring the codebase more
generally with our context engine so it
can kind of gro some of that assembly
code and start to think about what an
implementation would look like. That's
right. And it's actually like it's
running little terminal commands for us,
right? And it's not waiting for us to
intervene here. It's just doing it. All
right. So, it's mapped things out. Uh,
yes. All right. So, look based on So,
there's a little test file in here. Oh,
it already succeeded. Okay. It it got
ahead of me. So, based on the test
files, I can understand what the lunar
descent guidance class should look like.
So, it created the missing descent.py
file. Let's take a look at that and see.
So, there you go. So, it wrote
descent.py. It's a implementation of the
P65 vertical descent guidance. So,
Augment has indexed this entire
codebase. It's able to go look at it.
So, it found, you know, where it is in
the original source code. And then, I
got to tell you, it's easier for me to
read Python than it is to read assembly
code, right? But it's actually laying
this out for us. So, here's where the
position and velocity are. It's got the
desired velocity. It's got the gravity
fields. Uh, and then it pulls the
routine together, and it should actually
have a yeah, an algorithm in here called
P65 guidance that implements this in
Python. And so our final position as it
ran this here. Let me go let me catch up
with my uh with my chat.
Yeah. And it ran the simulator. Final
position this number of meters. Final
vertical and horizontal velocity. And
you can see that it landed, you know,
within our 0ero to one meters that we
would expect for our final simulation
values. So yay augment agent. Good job.
It landed on the moon for us. Okay. Most
of us are not landing on the moon as
part of our day job. So is this a parlor
trick? Is there something we can
actually learn here? So this is what I
would take back to a legacy codebase of
mine based on what we've seen today.
There's three basic steps. Number one,
anytime you pull this open, you're going
to try to use the agent to help you
understand on your own what's going on
in that codebase. So Augment agent will
index it for you. You can ask questions
in chat. You're going to be asking
questions like, what does this codebase
actually do, right? What is this piece
of the code? What does file XYZ do for
me? Are there style or convention things
going on here that I should be aware of?
uh and then you can start writing some
tests. So sometimes people ask like you
know if I am not sure I fully understand
this code am I going to know if the new
code that I create is actually correct.
So I think a blend of agent and chat
mode are going to help you out a lot
here. Use chat mode to predict what you
think the code should do. So in the case
of the p65 algorithm you know tell me
what I think should happen when I run
this lunar descent given these input
parameters and then have the agent mode
write some tests to check that behavior.
It's not always going to get it right. I
had a case where it was working with the
scheduler and it couldn't decide for
itself whether priority level zero was
the highest level or lowest level in the
system and you could convince it either
way. Like it's a classic thing an agent
would struggle with. So take the time to
go, you know, read yourself, right? Have
it surface those pieces of the code for
you and then, you know, you're an
engineer, you can apply your human
ingenuity to it and then modernize.
start converting small portions of the
code in modular fashion to the desired
language or you know style that you want
and apply those same tests to make sure
that you're not getting far a field from
what the actual functionality of the
code should be and that is not just a
strategy for success landing the Apollo
11 guidance computer on the moon but for
working with your code as well. All
right, once again you can try Augment
agent yourself uh for free at
augmentode.com. Uh bring your gnarliest
legacy code bases and refactoring
projects. I forget how many lines of
code are in the Apollo guidance computer
repo. It's thousands. Um I mean that's
reasonable for this, right? Yeah, it's
pretty small fry when it comes to like
enterprise projects these days. So, you
know, the real world equivalent of this
kind of thing might be like I've got a
Java 8 project. I want to go to Java 17.
That's really tedious, toilsome. How do
I pass some of that over to to AI? Yep.
That's the that's the like real world
equivalent. Yeah, that's right. And as
you can see, it's pretty fast, too. Um
and you can bring your green field
projects. There's no shame in that, but
uh the legacy ones I think are a little
bit more fun. That's all we've got. Yes,
sir. What about things like checking for
dependencies across like a large code
base? It loves to do that. Yeah. And it
can actually go back in. Yes, it can.
And you actually in 20 seconds you
actually saw a little bit of that here,
right? Where it went through and like
there were some missing files. It tried
to run Python and said, "Oops, it's not
installed. I'm going to use Python 3
instead." Right? There's it's happy to
do that in 12 seconds. Go ahead, Drew.
What you showed was test driven
development effectively. Yes.
Yeah. Agents love to reason and iterate.
So any way they can check their own
result is very helpful. So tests are
good for that. That's a great question.
We are out of time. Thanks everyone. We
appreciate you.
[Music]